>> Sean: REACTION TO THE BIG
BREAKING NEWS.
AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK OUT
JUNE 5 AND AVAILABLE FOR
RE-ORDER ON BARNES & NOBLE.COM,
IT'S CALLED "THE NATION ABOUT
AMERICA'S BIG COMEBACK."
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, NEWT
GINGRICH BUT NOT NOW.
SORRY.
YOU'RE FAMILY TO ME.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
TED EL
TED E
TED OL
TED OLSO
TED OLSON
TED OLSON A
TED OLSON AND
TED OLSON AND P
TED OLSON AND PAR
TED OLSON AND PARK
TED OLSON AND PARK P
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN A
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN AND
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN AND SH
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN AND SHAR
TED OLSON AND PARK PEN AND SHARY
ATKINSON TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
WHAT THEY WERE DOING FOR 1 1/2
YEARS AND THE DEEP STATE REAL,
FISA ABUSES REAL, SPIES IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ARE REAL.
YOU'RE THE GREAT HISTORIAN.
TELL ME WHERE IN HISTORY THIS
WILL STACK UP TO.
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S RAPIDLY
BECOMING THE BIGGEST AND MOST
SOBERING POLITICAL SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
SOMEBODY POINTED OUT EARLIER,
BACK WHEN J. EDGAR HOOVER WAS
SPYING ON LYNDON JOHNSON'S
BEHEST OF RICHARD NEXT SON, WE
THOUGHT IT WAS TERRIBLE.
WHEN THEY HAD A BREAK IN AT
WATERGATE, WE THOUGHT IT WAS
TERRIBLE, THIS IS A MULTIYEAR
EFFORT WITH TWO DIFFERENT
FRONTS.
PEOPLE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT.
ONE FRONT WAS PROTECTING,
COVERING UP FOR BILL AND HILLARY
CLINTON.
THE OTHER FRONT, AS TRUMP BECAME
MORE AND MORE SERIOUS, THE OTHER
FRONT WAS TO STOP TRUMP AT ANY
COST.
I BELIEVE THAT THE REASON YOU
SEE PEOPLE LIKE SALLY YATES GO
BERSERK, GENERAL CLAPPER THEY'RE
ALL GUILTY.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE IN THE
OBAMA TEAM THAT GETS THAT
RATTLED, THEY'RE SCARED TO DEATH
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GET DRAWN
INTO THIS.
THEIR ROLE WILL COME OUT AND IT
WILL INVOLVE I THINK FELONIES
AND FRANKLY I SUSPECT IT REACHES
TO PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA COULD HAVE HAD
THIS MANY THINGS GOING ON AND
NOT KNOWN IT BECAUSE HIS
ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY
CONTROLLING, VERY TIGHT AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO DISCOVER
ALL OF THE STUFF IN THE END ENDS
UP WITH THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
AND HAS THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SENIOR STAFF'S FINGERPRINTS ALL
OVER IT.
>> Sean: THE QUESTION REMAINS
WHAT DID HE KNOW, WHAT DID KERRY
KNOW AND SUSAN RICE AND WHAT DID
CLAPPER AND BRENNAN KNOW.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
UNMASKING.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT.
HILLARY GETS A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION AND THEN COMES THE
EFFORT TO UNDERMINE A PRESIDENT
OR CANDIDATE AND A
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU PUT SPIES AND YOU LIE TO
FISA JUDGES?
>> I THINK THE NUMBER ONE THING
THE AVERAGE EVERYDAY AMERICAN
CAN TAKE FROM THIS, THE
CORRUPTION WAS SO DEEP AT THE
TOP.
REMEMBER, WE'RE NOT TAKING ABOUT
THE EVERY DAY FBI AGENT DOING
THEIR JOB.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE AT
THE TOP.
THEY WERE SO CORRUPT AND SO
ARROGANT THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY
COULD GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
SO THEY JUST PROCEEDED DOWN THE
ROAD, PROTECTING HILLARY,
COVERING UPHILLRY, GIVING
IMMUNITY TO PEOPLE BREAKING THE
LAW AND GOING AFTER TRUMP AND
GOING AFTER TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
WHEN ALL OF THIS COMES OUT AS
ONE IN A WAY THAT IS EASY TO
UNDERSTAND, WHICH MAY TAKE
ANOTHER YEAR OR 1 1/2 YEARS
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH OF IT.
EVERY TIME WE TURN AROUND,
ANOTHER PIECE UNRAVELS.
YOU'VE HAD MORE BIG STORIES IN
THE LAST 1 1/2 YEARS THAN I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
AGAIN AND AGAIN, YOU'VE BEEN
RIGHT AND INCH BY INCH EVEN "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" IS STARTING TO
CONCEDE.
BY THE WAY, MARK PENN'S COLUMN
TODAY IS A REAL BREAK-THROUGH.
HERE YOU HAVE A GENUINE
INQUALIFIED MEMBER OF THE LEFT
SAYING THIS IS A THREAT TO ALL
OF US AND WE HAVE GOT TO GET RID
OF MUELLER BECAUSE HE THREATENS
EVERY AMERICAN'S FREEDOM.
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER, YOU
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU UNDERSTAND CHECKS AND
BALANCES, SEPARATION OF POWERS,
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY,
OVERSIGHT OF CONGRESS.
HOW DARE ROD ROSENSTEIN, WHO
ALREADY IS CONFLICTED IN THIS BY
RECOMMENDING THE FIRING OF COMEY
AND SIGNING ONE OF THE FISA
WARRANTS, HOW DARE THEY NOT TURN
THIS OVER TO CONGRESS?
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE DONE WHAT
SHOULD CONGRESS DO.
YOU'RE A FORMER SPEAKER.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S BEGINNING
TO MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE PRESIDENT IS BEGINNING TO
WAY IN TO REINFORCE THE
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
I THINK YOU -- GENERAL KELLY
BEING GIVEN THIS ASSIGNMENT IS A
VERY TOUGH, VERY SERIOUS MAN.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO IMPOSE ON
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOING
THEIR JOB OF TURNING OVER
LEGITIMATE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
EVERYBODY OUGHT TO REMEMBER, YOU
MENTIONED THE CONSTITUTION.
REMEMBER THAT WHEN THEY WERE
DONE WRITING IT, BENJAMIN
FRANKLIN WAS ASKED BY A WOMAN,
WHO HAVE WE GOT?
HE SAID WE HAVE A REPUBLIC IF WE
CAN KEEP IT.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE GREAT TESTS
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
CORRUPTION CAME CLOSE TO
DESTROYING THE LIBERTIES YOU AND
I BELIEVE IN.
>> Sean: IF HILLARY GOT ELECTED,